so I don't know I don't have anything
pulled up on the name you know calling
it Wuhan where it's just like this
Twitter rage where there's all this this
but these battles going on between it
was like a doctor that said it first
about you know Baba we should do we
prepare we should wash your hands you
know to counter this Wuhan virus and
then like all of a sudden the the woke
people were like whoa it's actually the
same guy so know that I saw that true
that's true he tweeted in January he's
the guy who started it who was okay hold
on hold on we got to get the context oh
yeah so go ahead I'm getting it out
order the the corona virus is wreaking
havoc on the economy and the supply
chain and it's been called Co it's
officially called kovat 19 it's been
called you know SARS kovat 19 or SARS -
and some people have referred to it as
the Wuhan virus or the Wuhan corona
virus because it originated in Wuhan
right a doctor on Twitter back in you
know
January it's generally we're like a
thirst and it's that guy what's the name
Eugene he called it the Wuhan
coronavirus right and then it was now
like recently two weeks a week ago he
was like calling it the Wuhan virus is
racist and now a bunch of people are
saying that these people have no idea
what they're talking about they're angry
they have no principles they have no I
they're just like oh what's what are you
mad about okay I'm mad about that - no
I'm gonna show how virtuous I am no
about what yard but the Wuhan virus
makes the most sense of what to call it
right did it not originate from Wuhan I
have an interesting story about that I
found a tweet the epicenter of kovat 19
corona virus is scrubbed from Wikipedia
whoa this is what obfuscation of factual
information there is an addendum don't
worry you have to click the kovat 19
outbreak linked to even see it as first
identified as if it was everywhere at
the same time of discovery within
minutes of posting this there was an
edit to the page saying it was quote
first discovered in Wuhan and quote it
was not there when I read it check the
Edit history first discovered still does
not state the origin of virus and
implies it was found everywhere before
someone
I'm what someone made an interesting
point how the Chinese are trying to wipe
that out so that it can be a global
thing and their fault and they can edit
Wikipedia right so they don't want
people to refer to as Wuhan because you
know that's a place in China it's their
fault that got out they were trying to
get rid of that there was a nice on
commercial release with brie Larson oka
from Captain Marvel yeah and it's like a
woke commercial ok and I bring this up
because I think it's funny that of all
of the things to actually get woke and
go broke coronavirus is one of them is
that what they are talking about well
they're saying you can't call it the
Wuhan virus it's racist Oh like you're
talking about this commercial didn't you
bring that up because it's like it's
another example of a big business being
like let's embrace feminism to sell a
product because that's what men want
when thinking about cars I know I know
they're targeting women but like as if
any human being is going to looking at
the comic line hmm but does it speak to
my feminist sensibilities but I'm only
bring that up because it's an example a
recent example of get won't go broke
where so now they're literally trying to
make coronavirus woke true like you
can't call it Wuhan virus but it's from
there and there's many coronaviruses so
calling it corona virus doesn't make any
sense is a corona virus dudes ours is a
corona virus MERS is a corona virus you
know but because you're literally out
there
you're literally explaining the problem
with woken us like there was another
story I covered today where people in
the UK are trying to get their passports
to say X instead of male or female okay
there's a reason why we put your your
biological sex in your passport there's
two reasons what are the reasons first
identification okay but that's that's
not even a secondary sure like the
medical reasons and physical reasons we
when we look at your ID to figure out
who you are we need to know if there are
certain things to take into
consideration true if you're
incapacitated like these are important
you know things so if we just say don't
call it
Wuhan virus call it you know corona
virus Ark ovid and people don't know
what that is because the colloquial term
has been Wuhan virus even these woke
people were calling it Wuhan virus yeah
now they want to change it how can we
actually know we're talking about if you
just change the word randomly without
explaining to anybody and then yell at
them if they use the wrong phrase
nobody gets better than that I laugh but
it's not funny no that's funnier it's
funnier oh great
coronavirus got woke it's the virus
itself no no like the circumstances you
don't understand it's not the names it's
not just the name all right go they
released what was that thing they
released the instructions for washing
your hands oh yeah and it was a white
hand in a black hand oh yeah washing
each other and it's like what was the
point you're trying to make I guess they
were concerned that if they did only the
hands being white to wash your hands
that people complained it was like white
supremacy but if they did the hands were
black than the the white people would be
mad like I don't know so they had the
right hand is white in the left hand is
black and now it just looks like two
people washing each other's hands
together it's like don't do that don't
find a partner take your left and their
right hand and you know you take your
right into their left and your left into
their right and you wash each other's
hands that's right that's how you that
way your own hands don't touch it's
crazy to me that this is how far it's
gone in terms of woke ridiculous you're
afraid they're afraid now of these crazy
people yeah yeah Witter it's like
Twitter so here's what happens Twitter
verse like just I've been just getting
back into Twitter and it's a scary world
there's so much craziness I see every
day I mean I'm I'm browsing and I'm just
like what is this well here there's some
cool people out there I got it I gotta
be honest there there is some at least
there is some level-headed people out
there well I thought that I'm reading
Adam you're their level headed here's
how I put it let's say there's ten
people in every city in the US okay
that's a psychotic woke lunatic yeah
there's these are the people who are
screaming at their walls in their
bedroom and like no one knows they're
doing it okay now you go on Twitter and
they all start screaming in unison and
it looks like a huge crowd of people so
this is a phenomenon we see all the time
here's what happens someone will go on
Twitter and say I don't happen I happen
to dislike vanilla ice cream and they'll
get ten messages where they're like
you're nuts this is gross how could you
not like vanilla and they immediately
assume if ten people are saying it the
whole world is saying it well so they
also get the other ten people that are
like
also hate vanilla vanilla worst people
people who agree don't respond and say I
agree for the most part it's the people
who hate you saying what's wrong with
you you bigot mmm what's wrong with
vanilla they're a bigoted against
chocolate ice cream so here's another
ice but here's it here that's happening
these companies like Gillette Nissan and
even now the coronavirus people you know
they they named it covet 19 on purpose
because they were worried that it would
offend people if they named it the wrong
thing really yeah yep
it started as Wuhan virus because here's
what happens we're all minding our own
business and then a company what Pepsi
will be on Twitter and they'll post like
we have launched a new green can of
Pepsi and they'll get like a hundred
messages for out of the millions of
people follow them saying this is gross
this is a offensive and racist and
they'll panic thinking the 100 people
actually what was it I think this was on
maybe the Simpsons our family I think
was Family Guy they were alike actually
no it might have been feature Alma where
they were like we received through a
write feature on reference well we were
watching it recently yeah they were like
we received ten phone calls and
according to Nielsen ratings that means
100 billion people are angry with us
that's what they do I think it I think
it might have been a Family Guy or
something that was it was yeah fathers
against something TV yeah yeah yeah yeah
so that clearly means that 10 billion
people are mad it's like there's not
that many people on the planet I don't
know how many with a population of the
you know thousand using the features but
that's the point so you end up with a
hand like this is how insane it gets a
hand washing graphic no one cares about
depicting two different hands washing
each other
my favorite tweet response was this this
shows what to do if one of your hands
gets a fatal skin eating disease was
like oh yeah white person with one hand
is getting disease to death no it could
be
vitiligo oh the lack of military so now
get their way around so now they were
being anti ablest with a that would be
able as to I don't know anti ablest by
showing someone with vent oligo just do
like blue hands yeah yeah for you no one
has blue hands it's perfect and it just
shows but you know what everybody
recognises a hand that's right yeah
that's blue and you wash it it's great
there's none there's been a bunch of
funny hand-washing memes one of them was
like the songs you can sing when washing
your hands because that way you can wash
them for the right amount of time oh
okay so it's like singing the chorus to
these songs and by the time you're done
you're done washing your hands okay and
and it's like you know Toto Africa but
then someone took a graph of all of the
steps in hand-washing and they they said
the opening to lawn odor s vu
they're like in New York City sex based
offenses are considered especially
heinous and it was showing the words for
each step and it was like they timed it
out so that if you recite the opening to
law and order SVU while doing all the
steps the perfect amount of time to wash
it and it ends with that's funny anyway
I I did the People's Court I think dead
an attendant then no yeah Lana order was
done boom okay yeah no no I can't say
I'm surprised that so so here's what I
was bringing up before they did it this
commercial I don't know why they do it
oh yeah but put it on right right right
I did it like I did a video about the
philosophy because it's called refused
to compromise okay that's terrible
advice
you look compromise is a good thing
sometimes I see so moral absolutism the
ability the ability to compromise that's
the important part
not always having the ability to
compromise you know not it's not always
a good thing but having the ability
means you're able to to see the need of
it
well yeah sometimes I think I think the
issue with like a 30-second bit where
she's like never compromise or like she
does refuse and does even make sense cuz
like basically the commercial is it
starts with a guy saying and so we're
not gonna be promoting you this quarter
cool and then the woman like you know
brie Larson pulled up and she goes get
in and she says like drop the taco and
then she jumps in the car and then brie
explains how everything in the car is
like a refusal to compromise it makes no
sense but like the weird thing is in no
reality I mean like you know okay it's
not fair but typically there's not some
guy just look at a woman to being like
for literally no reason I'm not
promoting you and then she goes oh rats
like they're so darn yeah and then ask
them if it's cool cool yeah Yeah right
remark no I like that so what I was
saying is like you could add one thing
one sentence to the beginning of that
cent thing the beginning of what he said
mm-hmm and it completely neutralizes the
entire commercial if he was like revenue
is down dramatically this year so we're
not gonna be promoting you this quarter
cool like should be like okay I wanna
keep my job so I'm gonna say alright and
then like if you keep looking into it's
like also we're not promoting anyone
including all of the the guys you can't
I'll admit like I'm sure there are
circumstances where some you know
douchey dude is like I mean giving you a
promotion because you're a woman or
something but it's just like that's a
caricature of real life I know but so so
of not not real life of just this crazy
bubble and well here but here's why I
bring it up i I can understand when I
see these these commercials like the
Gillette commercial like toxic
masculinity exhaust and and it's just
like a caricature of real life but I'm
like look to them the worst case
scenario is we're gonna generate buzz
we're gonna get flack from all the angry
people online we're gonna get a bunch of
news stories written about us and it'll
be worth way more and earn press by
doing this yeah and then people forget
about it that's their plan is right mmm
I can't I can't understand the current
virus thing like literally what is your
endgame for getting woke on coronavirus
I'm calling it the Wuhan virus if your
order this if you call it the Wuhan
virus no I don't know I mean like the
official designation of changing it from
one virus to covet right and showing the
hand-washing thing being two different
hands of different colors like there's
no endgame there what are you trying to
do just I don't think that's insanity me
that's that's like the delusional
paranoid state of people who exist on
social media who have no idea what the
real world is like freaking out and
being like yep no idea what the real one
you know you know exactly so you guys
have seen Doctor Strange yeah this is
one of the funniest things you know the
ancient one played by Tilda Swinton yeah
she's an Irish woman they Irish yeah I
think she is okay I don't I could be
wrong she's British maybe she's cool
though yeah look it up anyway here's the
story cool characters the ancient one in
dr. strange is an old Asian man with a
few Manchu in the original dog in the
original Doctor Strange okay
and so she's British and so they said we
want to change this because it would be
a stereotype to make an old Asian man
with a foo Manchu teaching martial arts
okay so we're gonna do a woman instead
that way it's you know we're doing we're
doing walk right right okay and guess
what happened whoa crowd was outraged
that they whitewashed a an Asian
character there's literally nothing you
can do these people are nuts but again
these people are the ten people in their
basement yes yelling and screaming that
don't represent the millions and
millions of people out there you can't
yeah virus that's racist woo Hansa City
you [ __ ]
yeah who is it racist against the
political that actually messed up in
Wuhan and set it out no it's races
against like the most racist country on
the planet did you know that they did
commercial in China where they put a
black guy in a washing machine and he
comes out Chinese are you see I'm not
even kidding and you're gonna try and
protect these lunatic authoritarians who
lock people in concentration camps to
harvest their organs that's crazy dude
yo got problems serious problems yeah
but I'll tell you what it is
all of these people screaming in their
bedrooms top of their lungs online form
a community they normally wouldn't have
right and so then they're screeching at
the top of their lungs and regular
passive liberal types are like okay
please don't yell at me and they back
away it all found each other here's
Bernie Sanders I think what ends up
happening is a lot of Trump supporters
and conservatives are kind of I don't
the right word is for headstrong okay
like don't you yell at me don't you tell
me what to do I'll do what I want
sounds American right and then you do
have liberals like that you're like you
and I are probably gonna be like don't
yell at me we're gonna do it like get at
our face you know and so naturally we
are pushed away from that mm-hmm and now
we're complaining about these people and
we'll be smeared I mean not so much you
because you don't you know because I'm a
nobody
no but like you're entering the fray so
but they'll call me right-wing for
calling people lunatics because clearly
only the left no the problem is regular
leftist arts one okay whatever you say
please please don't yell at me and then
people like me I'm like nah and playing
that game yeah I got a my house neither
it's it's it's not racist it's
ridiculous I know it's so wrong it
originated there and it makes sense the
name of a city yeah it's the city where
it started spreading it's there's all
these maps of like
the spread and it all starts at Wuhan
it's like okay it's not even it's not
even about the myths like literally like
this virus started in one day all right
moving on
no they literally had to change the name
because of it so anyway now it's like
there's a liberal versus conservative
thing happening where the Conservatives
are like so what if we call it Wuhan and
the Liberals are like yeah you're bigots
and thank you for giving us more a
mutant ammo to fight you with it's
clearly because it's like we were saying
early on that you gene guys the one who
he called the one virus before - yeah
exactly
Yellin jump en dance yeah now it's now
it's racist thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you